The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HAZEL SIVE: All
right, moving along,
I want to talk about
three things today.
The first is breaking
symmetry in the embryo,
leading to the first
differences that then go on
to amplify into many differences
in a multicellular organism.
And then I'm going to talk
about organic genesis and then
about morphogenesis.
And we'll define these
terms as we go along.
Let's start with this
question of breaking symmetry.
And I'm going to
start by going back
to the last handout
of last lecture
that you should have looked at--
hm, I wonder if our AV
expert could do something
to the screen.
I don't think it's the computer.
I think it's the screens.
Let's see if we can do this.
The last handout I gave
you was a consideration
of how different parts of
the embryo become different.
And I started off-- and you
might have this in front of you
still--
I started off with an
embryo, a fertilized egg,
that's got some kind
of asymmetry to it.
And I've called
it a determinant.
And at the first
cell division, look,
I've put that
determinant into one cell
and not the other cell.
One cell and not the other cell.
Now, let's say that
that determinant has
some effect on changing
the secreted factors--
oh, fantastic,
thank you very much.
It's like magic-- that
determinant has an effect.
And it actually elicits signals
to be secreted from the cell.
Then look what happens
at the next stage,
at the four cell stage,
here is a cell that's
secreting a signal.
And it's doing something to the
cell that receives the signal.
It's making it brown.
And that signal in turn
then elicits other signals.
So the brown cells
start signaling
to the cell next door.
And as cell division precedes,
you now get gray cell.
And this is a
theoretical, but a real,
demonstration of how the embryo
becomes different over time,
starting with an
initial asymmetry.
That is then built
upon due to segregation
of localized factors and also
due to cell-cell signaling.
And all of this comes
together to make
these different regions, which
I've cool territories, which
eventually will
go on to give rise
to different kinds of cells
or different groups of kinds
of cells.
If you look in a real embryo--
this is a fruit fly
embryo, Drosophila embryo.
You don't have a handout.
Just look on the screen.
You can see the
sequential division.
And you can see this by looking
at changes in gene expression
patterns.
And it's really spectacular.
This is a drawing.
But you can actually
look at this
in terms of in
situ hybridization,
that technique I
mentioned last time,
where one can look at
where RNAs or proteins,
and in the case of in
situ hybridization,
it's RNA, where
RNAs are localized.
And in the very
early embryo, there
is an asymmetry of
a protein called
bicoid, where there's more
on one side than the other.
A little later,
after fertilization,
you start to see literally
these stripes of RNA
or protein across the embryo.
And then the stripes of
different proteins and RNA
get narrower as the embryo is
divided up into its segments
and so on.
And so what you see out of this
is the embryo being divided up
from one large territory
into smaller and smaller
territories.
But the question is,
where does it all start?
And so the first asymmetry
has got something
to do with fertilization.
It can either occur before,
at, or after fertilization,
where the haploid egg and
sperm fuse to become a zygote.
And somewhere in this process,
this asymmetry develops.
In the case of frogs,
the first asymmetries
are formed before fertilization,
and also in Drosophila, fruit
flies.
In the case of
Caenorhabditis, also
known as the worm, asymmetry
forms at fertilization.
And in the case of mammals,
like ourselves, the asymmetries
appear to form of
to fertilization.
And these asymmetries
eventually build up
to give rise to a system
of positional coordinates,
kind of like the lines
of latitude and longitude
on the globe.
And these are called the axes,
which are positional values.
And there are three of them.
I'm just going to put the
initials on the board.
And then I'll show you a slide,
and you can get these later.
They're called a
A/P, D/V, and L/R.
And if you look on
the screen, you'll
see my diagram of a mouse,
the same in ourselves,
where there is this
A/P coordinate, which
stands for anteroposterior,
where antero is the head
and posterior is the tail, or
as far back as your body goes.
Then there's dorsal which refers
to back and ventral, belly.
And then there's left and right.
And these values are
kind of like north,
south, east, west,
and then degrees
on either side of the meridian.
They help the embryo
figure out where
to put different organs
in different cell types.
And I'm not going to dwell on
them in the interest of time,
but there are a
whole sets of genes
that are involved in setting
up these coordinates.
The one thing that
I will dwell on more
is a specific
example of setting up
the first asymmetry
in Caenorhabditis,
where this first asymmetry
is set up at fertilization.
And the bottom line-- we'll
look on it on your hand out
in a moment--
is that the sperm entry and
particularly the centriole
brought in by the sperm
causes a massive rearrangement
of the cytoskeleton in
the egg or in the zygote.
The cytoskeleton we mentioned
way back in Lecture 2.
It is the system of actin,
filaments, and microtubule
tubules that give the
cell shape and allow it,
as we'll discuss later
on, to move and to help
build the animal or the plant.
So this the sperm entry causes
cytoskeletal re-arrangement.
And this particularly pertains
to actin and tubulin, where
the tubulin forms
microtubules and the actin
forms microfilaments.
And with the cytoskeletal
re-arrangement,
a protein called Par
6, that is firmly
attached to the
cytoskeleton, is pulled
to one side of the zygote,
leaving one side of the zygote
with lots of par-6 on
the other side with none.
And at the first cell division,
one cell gets lots of Par 6,
and the other gets none.
And that gives you
your first asymmetry
upon which the embryo
builds to give rise
to all its different
cell types and organs.
So the cytoskeletal
re-arrangement pulls
the attached Par 6 protein--
and this is a
regulatory protein.
It doesn't matter
exactly what it does--
to the future anterior
side of the embryo.
And in doing so, it actually
sets up the anterior side
of the embryo.
Let's look at your first
slide or your first handout.
This is a diagram of
the early worm egg,
actually the very
early worm zygote,
because here is the egg
nucleus, called a pronucleus.
It's haploid.
The sperm pronucleus
has just entered.
And the cytoskeleton I've
represented by this grid.
And Par 6 protein is
represented by the red
that you can see on
the screen surrounding
the outside of the zygote.
Here's the sperm entry, causing
cytoskeletal contraction.
And with it, because par-6 is
attached to the cytoskeleton,
Par 6 is moved to
one side of the cell.
That's the most important thing.
Later on, the first
cell division along this
dotted line here.
And you can see that the
first cell, in the first cell
division, one of the cells
would get most of the Par 6
and the other cell
would get very little.
This is a very
beautiful mechanism
that's been worked out
really beautifully in worms.
Here's a movie that I
guess isn't going to work.
You know what, it
was working great
before I walked in this room.
But it's not going to work.
So I'm going to
post it as a movie.
And you can go to the
URL and you can get it.
And you'll see what
this movie does
will show you fluorescently
labeled Par protein.
It's actually a different
protein than Par 6.
And you'll be able to
see it moving beautifully
to one side of the
embryo and not the other.
Number 2, organogenesis.
An organ, as I've
written on the screen,
is a functional unit
of many cell types
that are arranged
obligatorily in
a three-dimensional
structure that allows
them to function together.
So the problem we have here
is that an organ is many cell
types, arranged in
3-D, such that there
is a specific
functional outcome,
like the heart pumps blood,
the kidney filters blood,
the eyes see.
All of these things require
both of these correct cell
types and 3-D organization.
And just this sentence
or just this phrase
raises two questions.
How do you get all the cell
types to the correct place?
And how are they put into
the correct structure?
Let's phrase the problem
by looking at the kidney.
The kidney is one of
the most complex organs.
It does two things.
It filters the blood and
gets waste products out
of the blood,
particularly products
of amino acid metabolism.
And it also maintains
water balance.
Both of those things
are crucial functions
of that kidney, which consists
of about 15 different cell
types, which are connected
into several types of tubes
that lead on fluidly
from one to the next.
You have one type of
tube that does one thing.
It's connected to
the next tube, which
does the next thing, connected
to the next tube and so on.
The tubes are very long.
They form a 3-D organization.
And they form filtration
units, called nephrons.
Here are part of the nephrons.
And you just have to look at
this without any knowledge
to see that this is
a complex structure.
This is a distant view, so
you can't see the cells here.
Low magnification structure.
This is a really complex organ.
And it takes a moment's
thought to wonder how something
like this gets put together.
And, of course, this is not
only important for developments.
It's important for thinking
about how you would replace
someone's kidney with
something that was artificial,
and not just using
donated organs.
Could you build
something like a kidney
and use it in place
of donated organs?
So the question of organogenesis
is of huge importance
both to basic researches,
to physicians trying
to understand what goes
wrong when organs fail,
and to bioengineers who are
trying to build organs that
would replace human versions.
Let's start by tackling
the first question.
How do you put different cell
types in the correct place?
And there are three
possibilities, all of which
are used by the body.
OK, so one, they can move there.
There can be all these cell
types all over the body.
And they can say, oh, OK,
we need to go move over here
to build a kidney.
OK, it seems unlikely,
but in fact, it's true.
And that process
would be migration,
where the cells come
from all over the place
to build the organ.
The cells need to
know where to go.
And that just pushes
the problem back one.
But the great example of
cell migration is the limb.
Most of the cells in
your limbs and mine
did not come right from
where the limb grew.
They migrated there
from the spinal cord.
from the muscles
on the sides of the body.
And the blood vessels also
grew in from the cells
that were distant.
So the limb puts it all
together by moving cells around.
How else could you get
cells to the right place?
See, it's not so easy.
OK, so here's another one.
Well, you could in one place
tell a bunch of different cells
to form at the same time.
You could have your
organ and say, all right,
we need cell types 1 to 10.
Form.
Here's some signals.
You will form in this one place.
And in fact that happens.
This is called
co-induction, where
many cell types or several
cell types form in one place,
often because one signal can
act at different concentrations
to give rise to
different cell types.
So many cell types
form in one place,
often due to a concentration
gradient of an inducer,
of a signal.
And the great example of this is
the spinal cord, and the nerves
in the spinal cord, which arise
by co-induction of actually
about two different inducers.
And the third one is called
sequential induction.
And this is how
the kidneys forms,
where the idea with
sequential induction
is that a cell type forms.
And it says, OK, I need this
other cell type to work with.
And it instructs
the cells around
to become another cell type.
And those cells in turn might
instruct some cells around them
to become another cell type.
And there's this
conversation going
on sequentially in the place
where the organ will form.
So cell type 1
induces or signals
to type 2, which
induces type 3, etc.
And a great example
of this is the kidney,
where I will say it is still not
known how you build a kidney.
Some of the steps
are understood.
But there's no
organ where we can
say these are all the
steps that build the organ.
It's incredibly complex.
Good.
That's all I'm going to say
about organogenesis, to throw
out at your this
complex problem.
And you can explore it
more in later courses.
I am going to talk more, though,
about this question of 3D
structure.
And that is the question
of morphogenesis.
Oranogenesis,
morphogenesis, you might
have heard of histogenesis,
which means building tissues.
The genesis part
refers to building.
That's what it means,
building of something.
Morphogenesis, building a
three-dimensional structure,
or the generation of
form is what you'll see.
And what that really means
is building 3D structure.
And this relates
to organogenesis
because in organogenesis
one of the things that's
hidden on the board
above was the question
of getting cells of an organ
into the correct 3D structure.
And, of course, this
question of 3D structure
is intuitively quite clear.
You can imagine a
human heart or having
some kind of animal's
heart in front of you.
It's an extraordinary structure.
It's actually a folded tube,
where the walls of the tube
have become very muscular.
And the heart will pump
with great regularity.
It's a controlled pump that can
speed up or slow down depending
on the how the animal is doing.
And that heart contains about
10 different kinds of cells.
And you can imagine having
one in front of you.
And you can imagine
my coming along
with some kind of
protease or calcium
free medium that will cause
the cells of the heart
to leave one
another, deconstruct
the structure of the heart.
Now you've got a heart
that's not this pump looking
tube structure.
It's a pile of cells.
The same cells that were in
the organ of the heart, but,
of course, they're not.
They're just a pile of cells.
They're all there.
They might all be alive.
But they're not acting.
And that's really an
engineering problem,
which is what
morphogenesis is all about.
And I want to just discuss
morphogenesis with you
because I think as a science
and engineering problem,
it's really an extraordinary
one to think about.
And it's extraordinary to think
about because really there's
only one building
material by which all
the structures of all organisms
are built. And that's cells.
You can't find different
plastics or different metals
or different alloys
to build things with,
it's just one building material.
And it's really
amazing what life
has managed to do with cells.
And that's what we'll explore
for the rest of the lecture.
So getting cells in organs
into the correct 3D structure.
This is a great example of
3D structure, another one,
the lungs, which are about a
20-fold iteration of branching.
You start off with one
tube, the trachea, which
branches into the two bronchi.
And those branch and they
branch and they branch.
It's about a 20-fold branching.
And you end up with
many, many little tubes.
In this rendition,
the ends of the tubes,
which are sacs of cells,
have been taken away.
But it's through these tubes
that oxygen moves or air moves.
The oxygen is extracted
from the air, moves
into the bloodstream, and
then the waste air is exhaled.
And the same thing starts again.
How do you build these lungs
with this branching arrangement
of cells?
And indeed, how do
you build the kidney?
You know, the problem
really phrases like this--
and if we had more time today,
I would sit and challenge you
for five or 10 minutes
to go and think
about how you take a pile of
cells from the early embryo
and build that
structure, which could
be what it is or
could be something
that represents an organ.
And while I'm moving
the boards, you
can think about how you
would take those cells
and turn them into
a 3D structure.
And we'll see if we have
concordance in our thinking
here.
All right, so let's
turn this pile of cells
into a 3D structure.
And let's pull
out some processes
that we can talk about in lay
terms, no scientific terms.
And then I'll put
some molecular labels
on that will help you understand
what we're talking about.
And process indeed has two s's.
There we go.
Well, one thing you
know if you look
at my pile of cells
in the 3D structure
is that those cells
have been sorted out.
I've put them in
different colors,
in groups of different colors.
So I'm going to write
that the cells sort out.
And there is a molecular
basis for that.
It's called homotypic
adhesion, where
like cells tend to
bind to one another,
so that they can
function as a unit.
But, of course, in order to
get the cells to sort out,
they actually had to move.
Yes?
Say, yes.
OK.
And they moved because
of their cytoskeleton,
which was rearranging
and changing and allowing
them to do so.
So the molecular
basis for movement
is cytoskeletal change
or rearrangement.
What else is on my list?
You know, the pile of
cells that I've got there,
it's meant to look
loose, like it
would be a pile of
cells that would just
spread out all over the
table if I dumped it out.
But the organ that I drew
is meant to look tight.
Those cells are stuck together.
And that is one of the
things that happens.
The cells stick together.
And they do so because of
cellular junctions, which
are particular
collections of proteins
that cause cells
to stick together,
often in a really
waterproof kind of a way.
The cells change shape.
They've gone from balls
to triangles to columns.
And that is also driven
by cytoskeletal changes.
And then the two lost
processes on my list
I'm not going to
explore more because we
had a whole lecture on them.
Cells can divide,
and they can die.
You can get rid of
the excess cells.
And you can generate
more cells to build
your organ by the processes of
cell division and cell death.
And we've had those
before, so we aren't going
to talk about those again.
But I will just put up cell
cycle control and apoptosis.
Good.
I-- yes?
STUDENT: What about the
[INAUDIBLE] the organ,
[INAUDIBLE]
HAZEL SIVE: Ah, great question.
The question is, how do
the cells know where to go?
How do they know that
the dark blue ones
are on the left and the columna
brown ones are on the right?
It's a great question.
And you know, if
we had more time,
I think that the
thing would come up
with was the notion
of some kind of plan,
that there are instructions
somewhere that are telling
the cells where to go.
What are those instructions?
Well, they're
somehow in the genes.
But it's more than that.
I don't think that
there is actually
a set of instructions
in the genes
that says build this organ or
the kidney or anything else.
There's a set of
instructions that unfolds
as the organ is being built.
And I think what's in the
genes are the first steps
of those instructions.
And then they kind
of unfold bit by bit.
So the outcome is the organ.
And there is some
kind of a plan.
But we don't have any evidence
that there's any kind of plan
actually written in the genes.
OK, it's a fascinating question.
Good.
Back to the toolkit.
This toolkit to build
all organs of cells.
But cells, you
know, are not just
equivalent to bricks one shape.
They can actually change.
So it's not quite fair
that I said to you
this is different
than engineering
where you've only
got one material.
It's true you've only
But it can change.
It can change its shape,
and it can move around.
And the two kinds of things
you really need to know
are involved are single
cells and cell sheets.
And single cells and cell sheets
are interchangeable from one
another.
Single cells are also
called mesenchyme.
[INAUDIBLE] [? they ?] are.
Single cell.
And groups of mesenchymal
cells can associate
to become sheets of cells.
And these sheets are
called epithelia,
or singular is epithelium.
Single cells migrate.
They move.
And there are no junctions
between the cells that
allows them to be single cells.
Epithelia, cell sheets,
can change shape.
But they don't move
around that much.
So they change shape as sheets.
And what that allows them to do
is to form coverings and tubes.
I should say one
very important thing.
The process is reversible.
If you look at the next handout,
there is more information
that you'll get.
Here's your epithelial sheet.
It's joined together
by junctions.
Let me make a note
that there are
junctions between the cells.
That's what sticks the
cells together is a sheet.
Here are the junctions.
There are two kind.
There's top ones
called tight junctions,
which are waterproof junctions.
And then they
these are the ones,
called adhesion junctions,
which aren't so strong.
Both epithelia and mesenchyme
sit on the extracellular
matrix, or ECM, which
we mentioned way back,
glycoproteins that are involved
in giving support and also
carrying signaling
molecules to cells.
And here is the conversion of
the sheet to the single cells,
and the single cells
back to the sheet.
This process of epithelial
mesenchymal transition
or mesenchymal
epithelial transition
is very important in cancer.
Tumors usually start
off as epithelia.
The And they become metastatic.
They disperse
throughout the body
when they become mesenchymal,
or when they give off
single cells, which can
migrate and establish
the tumor somewhere else.
So this process is crucial
both in building organs
and in cancer biology.
The other thing that
you should note--
we're not going to
dwell on it very much--
is that the cells in a
sheet have got orientation.
They've got an axis of
asymmetry along one side,
call the apical basal axis
and an axis of asymmetry
along the top, called
the planar axis.
But we're not going to
dwell on that very much.
All right, let's look
what epithelial sheets
do in a little more detail.
So epithelial sheets or
epithelial form waterproof
coverings, as I've noted.
And through cell shape changes,
they'll also bend a cell sheet
or turn it into a tube.
And they do this by a series
of stereotypical changes,
where cells can change shape,
so that kind of a square cell
can become an elongated cell in
one direction or a cell that's
elongated in a
different direction.
Or it can become a
wedge shaped cell.
And the names of these
different kinds of cells
don't really matter.
And they're not sequential.
So this cell can
become this cell.
It can also become this wedge
shaped cell in one fell swoop.
But if you think about it,
these changes in cell shape
can do lots of things.
For example, if cells
get long and thin,
then the cell sheet
will lengthen.
If cells get wedge shaped,
and you've got a whole bunch
of them getting wedge shaped--
you can draw this out--
you'll actually
bend the cell sheet.
Draw it out.
Put a whole bunch of wedge
shaped cells next to one
another.
And you'll see there's no
way you can get a flat sheet.
The cell sheet bends.
And that is one of
the things which
drives building the
structure of organs.
There are a lot of different
ways to make tubes.
I've diagrammed them
on the next few slides.
You don't have these.
Cell sheets can roll
up to form a tube.
Mesenchymal cells can
condense, can come together,
to form a tube.
And here's a really
extraordinary one.
Single cells can form tubes.
Tiny, single cells with
a 10 micron diameter
can roll up on their
cell themselves
or actually hollow
out their middles
to become tiny, tiny tubes.
What about single cells?
Single cells move.
And this allows
things to sort out
and cells to get to
where they need to go.
But we're also going
to use this property
to understand the
molecular principles that
underlies cell shape change.
And that you should know.
Let's make a note
that single cells move
and that this allows cells to
sort and tissues and organs
to form.
And then what I'm going to tell
you over the next few slides
and on your handouts is that
all of the movement and all
of these shape changes
that I drew on the board
have got to do with changing
the cytoskeleton of the cell.
But what I'll tell
you is that it's
about locally changing
the cytoskeleton,
where you have to stop
viewing the cell as something
huge, where independent
things can happen
in different parts of the cell.
And those independent
changes in the structure,
in the skeleton of the
cell will get the cell
to become long or squat
or wedge shaped or moved.
So shape and movement of
both sheets and single cells
is controlled by changing
the cytoskeleton.
But it's done so locally, which
means in one part of the cell.
And a most important change
that occurs as the cytoskeleton
changes or with cytoskeletal
changes or is cytoskeletal
change is a polymerization
of actin from G-actin,
which is unpolymerized,
to F-actin--
and this is reversible--
which is polymerized,
non-covalently.
And this F-actin
will stretch the cell
and help the cell to move.
And let's explore
that in this movie
and in the rest
of your handouts.
This is a movie of a
cell, where the actin has
been labeled fluorescently.
And what you can see
as the cell is moving
are these little
filaments of bright green.
Those are the
polymerized F-actin.
And you can see if you just
focus on one, over the course
of minutes, it goes away.
And new ones form.
And the new ones are
forming in the direction
that the cell is moving.
And this movie really
illustrates the principles
underlying how the
cytoskeleton is controlled.
Let's draw something
on the board
or let's write a few
things on the board
and then look at your
last two handouts.
And what you'll understand is
that the principles governing
actin polymerization are really
the same for both single cells
and for cell sheets.
The idea here is that the
extracellular matrix, the ECM,
connects to the plasma membrane
via receptors on the plasma
membrane.
When ligands bind
these receptors,
you know what happens now.
Signal transduction
is activated.
So the ligands plus
the receptors--
and there are many
different signaling pathways
that can be involved--
go and activate a
cascade of things,
which involve kinases, a
signal cascade via kinases
and via special GTPase.
Remember Ras was a GTPase,
but this one is called Rho.
And Rho GPTase it's
critical in telling G-actin
to polymerize and form F-actin.
And so out of this
the Rho GPTase
tells G-actin to form F actin.
And with that,
various things happen.
So let's look at
your last handouts.
Here's the cell migrating.
And the thing that
I want you to see
is that in the
direction of migration,
there are receptors that
are bound to ligands.
Signal transduction
has occurred.
I've diagrammed it down here.
And F-actin, these
little filaments,
have formed in the direction
in which the cell is moving.
And where the cell is
detaching so that the cell can
move forwards-- you have to
lift up your foot in order
to move forward.
It's the same thing
with the cell--
where the cell is moving
forward, they're no ligands.
And there's no F-actin.
That principle is
crucial also in changing
cell shape and sheets.
It's a little more complicated.
But, again, there are receptors
that interact with Rho GPTases,
change the cytoskeleton
and cell sheets
and change the shape
of the cell sheets.
And this is really the
molecular underpinning
that will get those single cells
to form tubes and bench sheets
and all of the materials that
are needed to build organs.
And we'll stop there.